if you give users the ability to play
with the parameters see what other
people see
right that
could potentially be a game changer with
respect to how we understand each other
yeah i love that i love that you combine
it with with the marketplace idea
because uh that way there would be
innovation in these sliders right okay
what kind of not just right left that's
kind of stupid how about open-minded
versus closed-minded how about neurotic
versus anti-neurotic right uh you know
you could sli you could have all kinds
of interesting ideas uh or you know or
again someone could actually put i want
to look i want to look at the world the
way kim kardashian looks at it for 30
seconds before i went insane right and
there'd be lots of innovation in the
features around feeds so i love your
idea i definitely have never thought
about that that's a that's a great one
i'm stealing that
i'll give credit when i remember that
brett weinstein said that we should uh
have
sliders on our feed owl goals and
be able to switch
shoes with other people and see the
world from there that alone see the
world from their perspective for even if
it's just an hour would be really quite
valuable
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am of course am dr brett
weinstein and i have the distinct
pleasure of sitting today with my good
friend jim rutt jim is a podcaster he is
the host of the jim rutt show he is a he
is the former chairman of the santa fe
institute which studies complexity he is
a tech entrepreneur and investor and he
is a co-founder of the game b movement
jim welcome to the dark horse podcast
yeah it's a pleasure to be here and
reconnect with uh with brett we've had
some good times over the years we
certainly have now am i right i was
looking back over our history and i
think i've been on your show a couple
times but this is your first time on
dark horse is that right that is correct
wow all right well that is a mistake
that we are correcting as of this moment
i should probably uh alert my
my viewers to who you are and what our
connection is some of it will be evident
to people from that introduction
but you and i met
when
you and jordan
hall who was then known as jordan green
hall
invited me to what was not yet the game
b movement at the time it was called the
emancipation party
um we can possibly get into some of that
history later if it becomes relevant but
nonetheless uh i met you as a i would
say long since
recovered
um
reaganite right winger i think you have
told me that your
your reaganite position began to break
down in the early 90s is that correct
yeah i was basically i was i was a
goldwater republican in fact i one time
wrote in goldwater it was a 1984
presidential gop primary in cambridge
massachusetts which was quite humorous
uh because reagan had pissed me off
about something rather so i considered
myself a goldwater republican until
1991.
with the demise of the ussr
rabid anti-communism was which had been
my main attraction to the republicans uh
went away as a main issue and i kind of
started getting reposed by the other
parts of the coalition in 92 i actually
voted for bill clinton and have uh never
voted for a republican presidential
candidate since
very interesting
so uh i will say you know it's funny i
look back at all of the uh
the hyperventilating anti-communism of
the era you describe and
um
yes it looked crazy on the other hand
now that i see
all
sorts of communism arising in all sorts
of minds without most of them even
realizing that that's what they are
invoking it looks different to me now uh
in some sense that the the paranoia was
partially paranoia and partially uh
far-sighted and maybe not as articulate
as it might have been about what the
hazards were maybe it didn't even really
know yeah i would say that's fair though
i will say i do have not and will not
ever repent for my fairly aggressive
anti-marxist leninism back in the day no
i think uh history has actually borne
out the hazard and i must say i've done
a good bit of thinking
in the time since you and i met
about what the hazards of communism are
why they exist whether they're solvable
and i've concluded that in fact it is a
a malignant perspective inherently that
even if it starts with good intentions
it inevitably evolves in a direction
that's that's devastating and we are now
watching this unfold in various places
we're seeing one version of it
in china we're seeing another version of
it domestically but
it leads nowhere good and one of the
jobs i think people like you and me
have is
to articulate the reason that it cannot
work and that even if
it has sympathy from you on the basis
that it it has an objective that sounds
good
that that objective is something that
can only be achieved with a different
mechanism one that is game theoretically
well constructed uh so anyway maybe
we'll get back to that later but when
you and i met
i know that you regarded me as a
uh a far
uh
a far left person and probably regarded
me with some suspicion as a result of
that i think you and i came to an
understanding very quickly that those
labels aren't particularly
evocative of the actual
programs and suppositions running in
each of our minds and anyway we've
become good friends and i know that
you're certainly somebody that i find
always has a fresh perspective on things
that i'm uh grappling with
and
i would have a very hard time
placing you politically on the map you
uh you're independent-minded on every
front
and that has been
uh i believe an excellent match for an
era in which there just simply is no
cheat sheet that tells you you know one
side doesn't have it right basically
everyone's got it wrong and so if you
don't have an a la carte
view of what
policies you might want to see enacted
then
basically you're in the weeds
and i think that describes me pretty
well i mean in like say in economic
matters i'm probably to the left of
bernie right
on the other hand i'm a second amendment
uh pretty strong guy but not an
absolutist uh you know when it comes to
uh things i uh climate change i take
that right seriously don't believe it's
uh bogus by any means right and uh and
so you know i choose what i believe to
be true and i guess what makes uh me
makes other people uncomfortable
sometimes and are talking to me about
politics is that i i just seem to lack
the gene uh for the tribal knee-jerk
right i don't feel at all compelled to
associate myself with one of the
political tribes
and i think that was one of the things
that we were trying to do with the
emancipation party uh was to go off in
an orthogonal direction something that
uh actually spent no time thinking about
left or right then when i go back and
read the emancipation party reforms you
know in in
19 2012 when we did it you would have
called it left uh to a quite degree and
oh by the way those old reforms are
still up on the internet i still pay the
10 bucks a month or whatever keep it up
emancipation
emancipationparty.org
i don't think you can find it with
google but you can type in
emancipationparty.org and read our uh 10
reforms and all that stuff but what they
didn't do is get into the identity
politics stuff and that's where uh in
some sense modern
the modern
two-dimensional red blue was stupid
anyway but now when uh the blue team has
essentially abandoned uh economic uh
opportunity and egalitarianism as the
basis for their uh for their whole
political perspective and instead has
turned it into
identitarianism essentially uh
neo-tribal racism the way i would
describe it uh you know uh makes me not
interested in uh those far far reaches
at least this you know the second half
of team blue
uh yet i'm still as i say left to bernie
on economic matters probably and uh and
that's okay by me yep yeah i must say as
you know and as some of uh some of my
viewers will know
my sense is that one of the mistakes
that we made
in uh in our collaboration over the
emancipation party and game b is that
the emancipation party evolved into game
b rather than the emancipation party
becoming a project of game b and my
sense is that history very quickly
bore out the idea that there was room
for a third party
effort and one that was well constructed
and non-ideological and uh
non-identitarian would have been very
popular we now see andrew yang of course
trying to boot up something like that
obviously there's the uh unity 2020
effort which uh you know was never
widely uh understood but was certainly
caught the attention of of some
influential people and
anyway there's clearly a hunger for some
alternative to the duopoly and there's
also an awareness that basically we're
stuck in a trap in which
every time somebody comes up with this
obvious idea
they become you know uh
basically
they're portrayed as unwitting dupes of
the greater evil and effectively we have
to escape that puzzle which is why unity
2020 was structured the way it was to
make that to neutralize that concern
but in any case i think the emancipation
party was a great idea a few years ahead
of its time a few years
if we kept with it uh you know we it
might well have gotten some traction but
the time wasn't right it was just too
hard and i think the fact that many of
the leading figures were business dudes
uh led us to a premature
abandonment you know us business guys
well [ __ ] and we're not getting traction
and we tried six different things we
didn't get traction on any of them so
guess i guess this is not the product to
sell at this point in time and that's
probably was probably accurate but if we
had uh waited three or four years the
times might well have been better uh for
this orthogonal uh with my my uh wife uh
who was member of the emancipation party
in the early game b movement calls
pragmatic progressivism
uh as uh and i think that's really what
the ep was all about and and there's
such a gigantic hole in the center like
there's never been before and and just a
final reminder i did buy the domain name
brett weinstein 2024
and so whenever you're ready let me know
i think there are a lot of people hoping
that i don't even survive till 2024 so
anyway
public goods was one of our very first
sponsors and we are as pleased with them
now as we were when we first tried their
products
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for everyday essentials
their ingredients are carefully sourced
high quality and their products are
affordable
public goods has coffee and tea they
have grains and oils like olive and
avocado
they have castile soap trash bags and
essential oils
they have spices and extracts like
vanilla and almond
vinegar and pasta dishware and glassware
there is so much at public goods to make
a meal including the materials to serve
it on
public goods products have a great
design too
the aesthetic is simple and clean there
are no garish colors
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are free
of harmful ingredients and additives and
their ingredients are ethically sourced
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store a little
like that other internet everything
store but without even a hint of evil
for darkhorse listeners we have the
following offer
receive fifteen dollars off your first
public goods order with no minimum
purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again that they are
giving you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first purchase
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse or use
the code darkhorse at checkout
that is publicgoods.com p u b l i c g o
o
dot
darkhorse to receive 15 off your first
order
the interesting thing about what you're
describing is that if the emancipation
party was ahead of its time it was so
barely ahead of its time that something
is wrong with any system that would uh
would declare it so on the basis that it
missed by three or four years right and
so one of the things i think we've
learned from what happened with the game
b movement
when the game b movement came apart when
it stopped being a group of people who
was
meeting in a physical space that you had
rented
for us
you described what it was that you were
doing and terminating that effort is
putting it into spore mode in my
language i would say
that game b was a prototype and i was
focused from the beginning on
seeing how far we could go and at the
point that it failed
learning what the lessons of that
failure were so that game c or game d
could do the job because something
certainly has to
and in any case no matter what language
you use whether it's spore mode or
prototyping or navigation or any of
these metaphors
what we do see is that the concept of
game b
um has actually caught on and it's
acquired some
uh of its most powerful thinkers in the
aftermath of the stage in which there
were actual physical meetings anywhere
right so people
who pay attention to dark horse will
probably know daniel schmucktenberger
for example he
is an important feature of the game b
movement though he came to it i don't
even think we knew who he was at the
point that we were meeting in physical
space so
in any case
somehow we've got to get out of the
business mindset where the idea is oh
the emancipation party isn't getting any
traction it must be the wrong idea and
kill it off and get into a different
mindset where as soon as we know that
something has to occur the question is
well
how do we continue how do we put this
thing into a low cost like a seed or
spore into a mode where it doesn't cost
anything to just idle so that at the
moment that the temperature is right it
can be unveiled and we're not starting
from scratch
that worked with game b right the spores
uh rehashed in 2018 uh due to
some fortuitous things basically of a
essay that uh jordan hall wrote and then
it's you know it's now going it's pretty
pretty big it's at least 30 000 people
that would identify themselves as game b
uh we recently put out a film uh people
can check it out at gamebeefilm.org
uh we have a online community a few
thousand people at game dash b dot o r g
better put it www uh behind that for
some reason the hosting company can't
figure it out without the www
and uh there's some uh real activities
uh starting proto bees the the building
of on the ground communities two already
exist though neither of them are what
i'd call in pure form and i know of at
least 20 other groups that are working
uh to figure out how to pull the capital
together and the team just together etc
and two of them are pretty far along
yeah i would say it's done exactly the
right thing it's not only uh managed to
persist through that period
but it has diversified so we've got
proto-b's we've you know various people
who were part of the game b movement or
who quickly
uh
found us or we found them have their own
versions people in other words have
taken the idea and they've forked it and
you know for heather and me the last
chapter of our book
uh talks about the fourth frontier which
is explicitly our take on what a game b
future would have to look like for those
who don't know what we're talking about
game b wise
game b is a very simple idea it's not a
plan but it is an idea
that our system is on a fatal trajectory
and that it requires if we are to
persist
it requires
that we
find a better solution and the key
insight the thing that makes it better
than every other version of this idea
is that game b whatever it is has to be
game theoretically stable it has to be
an evolutionarily stable strategy
it has to beat game a
in
its own terms in other words we can't
say here is a blueprint of a better
society now let's start a revolution win
the power to make it etc it has to be so
good that it is effectively contagious
and displaces game a
in a world that has been structured by
game a
and it is a you know it is a non-utopian
uh analytical approach to solving that
problem so
anyway i think those of us who
understand
why that has to be the general form of
the solution
effectively can't and won't walk away
with it we may never accomplish it but
we know that someone must and
until it is accomplished effectively
the short time horizon of modern
civilization is presently structured and
the potential
extension indefinite extension that
could be achieved if we got to this game
b
space
it's obviously the right thing to do
whatever the form that it takes might be
and i would just add one thing you get
all the main biggest points uh the other
it's in this non-utopianism this is
critical is that it we have an empirical
and experimental perspective uh many of
the people involved in formulating the
original game d idea either had a
background in complexity or were
infected by it or it's near neighbors
like evolutionary theory
and if you know anything about these
domains you know the ability to predict
the unfolding of a complex system over
any extended period of time is bupkus
right
you can't do it uh you can in fact the
whole definition of an emergence and
complexity is something which cannot be
predicted
with any plausible amount of computation
at least from the current state of the
pieces and so uh very important in game
b thinking is that we have a theory we
sort of have a destination but we hold
it very lightly and we try things we
probe systems we build little things we
experiment we analyze and then we share
the results horizontally whether they
worked or not and that makes us totally
different than
guys that show up with this tome that
says here's the truth if we just did
this uh we'll solve all mankind's
problems we know where that generally
leads which is to the gas chamber yeah
to gulag starvation gas chambers that
kind of thing
yeah i would say i would counsel us to
stop talking about vaguely knowing the
destination and i think if we talk in
terms of knowing the trajectory we know
what direction we should be heading but
we also know that we will be surprised
by the final structure if we allow
ourselves to be taught by the complex
system about what the real rules
actually are and as far as the
utopianism goes as you probably know
i've said many times i think
that utopia is the worst concept that
anyone ever came up with right it's this
very seductive
impossible place and
that it has you know as you point out
led to all kinds of tragedies of history
but
when people hear you say that they
sometimes get the sense of like oh i'm
no longer so interested because it
sounds like
some brutal pragmatic future that isn't
very exciting and my point would be look
in a complex system we know that there
are no perfect solutions there is
nothing like utopia but take a good look
at a hummingbird sometime
it's non-utopian it's built with uh
feedbacks right that's how it works but
step at a time somehow it got to the
hummingbird isn't that amazing it got to
the hummingbird and if you look at it
and you say yeah that's the level of
imperfection we might be shooting for
it's pretty darn good right it's pretty
close to what any rational person would
call a miracle if you didn't know that
there was a process that had built it up
incrementally and so anyway non-utopian
doesn't mean it couldn't be marvelous
it means it won't be marvelous right
away it will take a long time to get
where we're going and it will be
surprising in its structure because
there's no one on earth who can
blueprint it from here
amen brother and by the way the
hummingbirds have just returned to our
farm we have they've just come back here
too i'm never tired of watching them
either never never have it on our porch
i mean hummingbird feeders on both ends
and watch them go at it it's fun it's
beautiful i i as of this morning maybe
on the trail of a nest i've never had a
nest that i could watch them raise
chicks in so anyway i'll i'll keep you
all posted on whether or not i figure
out where it is but let's get to the um
the heart of the matter that has us uh
podcasting together today
you as of i think this morning
have a new article
out on colette excuse me colette
is that right correct correct all right
so i will say i have at the moment a
kind of a fraught relationship uh with
colette um claire lehmann having
ruthlessly uh attacked heather and me
over the course of at least the last
year plus but anyway let's put that
aside i uh initially was a huge fan of
colette and in principle i still am
although i
can't help but
um
be somewhat annoyed at her uh her
approach to someone i think she would
have called a friend but nonetheless
you have an article out
your article is about
elon musk's acquisition of twitter and
what it may mean to us and in fact i
think it's fair to say that your article
contains some guidance that comes from a
very long history not only of thinking
about
structures and complexity and ways that
systems
like twitter can be improved but also
very directly a long history of
participation
in
online forums of every kind right you
you have as long history as anybody i
know stretching back too long before
uh any of the structures on the modern
internet i mean back into the bulletin
board days am i right about that or that
even back to 1981 right to the very
beginning uh i designed i wrote i uh
early forum software uh i managed uh
many to many communications businesses
as a product manager as early as 1982.
uh you know to this day i'm uh
part owner of the well which is the
oldest surviving i think online uh
virtual community which still to this
day has amazingly high quality uh
discourse even though it's quite small
community we sometimes joke it's the
colonial williamsburg of the internet uh
and so yeah i've been doing this for a
long time and of course i run the uh
help run the game b
platforms and you know been involved in
various things and so yeah that was the
idea was to bring what i have learned
from watching
it with real bullets uh
you know how hard it is to make virtual
community work uh and uh you know take
and you know take some of what elon had
to say and kind of mix it all together
and talk about his critics and then lay
out uh how i think he may be on the
right path and that his some of his
critics at least are guilty of
gross straw manning uh and not talking
honestly about what's going on
and uh yeah so that's basically was the
intent and i do hope he reads it and
i've actually been trying to explore my
connections to people see if i can get
somebody to get into his hands and maybe
i will maybe i won't i'll let you know
if i do well i think there's a decent
chance
um
that
this conversation will cause him to take
a look at it
i will certainly
there will be a link to your article in
the description of this podcast
and i tweeted my own thoughts about
things that i felt were necessary
to a
a functional
twitter environment before reading your
article this morning
um and i tagged him so i don't know that
he he will see any of those things
obviously the amount of traffic aimed at
him is absolutely staggering and so it's
possible
uh
for anything to get lost but nonetheless
there's
so much in what you wrote that is i mean
for one thing
your central point or at least your
initial point is so obviously um
clarifying with respect to how you know
there's a fundamental paradox that
anybody who's thought
about the question of free speech has to
grapple with which is
you
effectively either forego all moderation
and you create an instant dystopia
because of all the terrible things that
can happen or you sign up for some level
of moderation and then the point is you
become responsible for where you draw
that line and there's no good way to
make everyone
happy but your point if i understand you
correctly
is that there's actually a very natural
place to draw a line that will not make
everyone happy but it is maximally
likely to be useful as a you know a
first stroke on the canvas and that uh
you want to lay it out sure and uh
because exactly because there's so much
of the reaction to the idea of musk
taking over twitter was extremely
simplistic and i actually quote in the
article two experts world-class experts
say oh elon's gonna have no moderation
at all it's gonna be the law of the
jungle etc right and he previously laid
out on the ted talk which i have a link
to in the essay that he you know he
obviously knows there has to be some
moderation so i thought about a little
bit and said how can we explain this
what is lacking in this conversation and
i realized it was frankly some a simple
ontology and vocabulary problem uh
because people are thinking
simplistically moderation yes moderation
no free speech absolutist you know uh
totalitarian fascist dictatorship nope
wrong and so the ontology i laid out the
vocabulary i laid out is to distinguish
first
content moderation from what i call
decorum moderation uh decorum could also
be called behavior
basically decorum which i talk about
first is uh analogous to manners in the
real world uh i i use the example for
instance uh yeah we might share the uh
the gory details of our most recent
dating debacle with our close friends
over a few drinks but we're probably a
lot likely to do that at our
grandmother's sunday dinner table and
the distinction between manners with our
friends over drinks and manners at our
grandmother's uh
dinner table correspond to
decorum rules in different kinds of
online venues for instance
you know a family oriented online system
like disney might have one set of
decorum rules a more serious one like
uh twitter for adults might have a
different set and uh you know 8chan
might have an entirely different one and
it's absolutely key
uh to the success of a platform that you
think about what you're uh who your
audience is what your purpose is and you
craft
a decorum a set of decorum rules into
quorum moderation that's appropriate for
what what you want uh you know in a case
like twitter
and many more or less mainstream ones
some of the obvious forms of decorum are
uh you know no racial slurs directed at
people i prefer the rule of no personal
attacks directed at another person uh
that's a member of the community uh you
know
there's some funny ones like uh
facebook has a rule no nipples the only
time i ever got a sanction until i got
banned by facebook was i posted a story
about uh uh
uh
kind of hippie communes and on the
picture that was pulled forward there
was a
like a four-year-old child with long
hair couldn't tell the uh the gender
or the sex to be more precise
and
nipples were showing so uh facebook uh
kicked it so that's quorum you can be
absurd and ludicrous like facebook is or
you can be uh you know smart and you
know be
and enumerate uh what it is that we are
are not going to allow you know in our
game b online home for instance we have
you know one death penalty rule which is
if you direct obscene language at
another member you will be terminated
instantly period uh as an example of a
forum rule which we enforce and it
actually was named after a specific user
who was what's the uh was the cause for
it and so
if you think about the other thing about
decorum is it's viewpoint neutral uh
whether you're talking about trump or
whether you're talking about bernie you
can say so using decorum without
attacking other people if the rules for
this particular platform were saying you
could use the george carlin no seven
dirty words you know i'd be out of luck
because i don't know how to talk without
using the seven dirty words but one
could imagine a platform that might
choose to do that now you could talk
about anything uh with decorum you know
i like to point out the beatles never he
said [ __ ] in any of their songs right
yet they were pretty revolutionary dudes
uh and so you can uh you know the quorum
and then the other side content are two
different worlds if you make that divide
cleanly uh i think you get rid of an
awful lot of the confusion uh that uh
that the discussion around moderation
has falls into in the simplistic uh all
or nothing perspective yeah i would say
it's likely to be you know who knows
whether there's actually a justification
for this but you might you might find
that it's a pareto you know you've
nailed 80 percent of what people
want protected versus what people want
excluded with the single you know the
single stroke
now uh i want to take you to two places
here first off
there is bound to be some confusion i
have described myself as a free speech
absolutist but i am for a solution like
the one you describe and i would um
reconcile those two things in this way
in environments like those
historically that have existed one does
not need absolute rules over decorum
because they are effectively agreements
in a community about what is and is not
tolerable behavior and they're obviously
uh you know there's variation but the
basic point is certain things are
outside of what this community typically
tolerates and um one can certainly
simply infer those and in fact you might
be very much in favor of those rules of
decorum as i am and very much against
absolute rules you know posted on the
door that say what will happen to you if
you violate this rule the basic point is
we don't want this to be authoritarian
we want it to be
voluntary and the point is
you can't have it be voluntary in a
space like twitter right we're not
anywhere down near dunbar's number where
so many orders above it or orders of
magnitude above it that
what could be done informally in another
context must be done formally at the
level of something like twitter and so a
free speech absolutist is not saying
everybody should say everything that
crosses their mind at all moments
right what they are saying is that we
want to be very
careful
uh not to create any limit that could
potentially um
uh eliminate some kind of valuable
perspective we need to protect all sorts
of speech that may not be obviously
valuable in order
to make sure to catch everything that is
valuable
so
um
let me go on to the other distinctions
if you if you don't mind yep yeah so
decorum and again different sites will
have different decorums and
i'll sort of finish up on what you were
talking about in a face-to-face
community it's generally speaking uh
implicit and also interestingly you have
skin in the game if you're in my face uh
talking about my mother guess what i
might punch in the nose right uh you
know
somebody sitting in their mother's
basement typing away on their computer
uh 3 000 miles from nowhere you don't
have that skin in the game and so you
have two things there's skin in the game
right like literally
there's literally skin in the game you
might take a punch if you say the wrong
thing
there's also reputation right it is not
so diluted by the number of users or the
anonymity or any of these other features
yeah if you're part of a face-to-face
community and you're known as the
[ __ ] that you know uh just dishes
[ __ ] to everybody nobody invites you to
any events anymore and they when they
cross the street when they see you
coming uh you know community of the
dunbar number of 150 plus or you know
plus times two baby uh so yeah so now
let's go on to the next distinction
which uh we have content versus decorum
and that's a pretty bright line yeah
there's a few edge cases but if you stop
and think is this a decorum question or
is this a content question it's usually
pretty clear
now in content i have a second uh
distinction that's a little muddier
which is between uh
actually uh
bad inherently bad content that again
most everybody would agree is bad though
there'll be some corner cases for
instance uh
uh attacks on privacy doxxing right uh
the uh
the advocate the advocacy of
imminent violence against specific
people or groups
uh the advocacy for the
committing of serious crimes now it's
interesting i make a distinction in the
article about serious crimes because i
uh might well allow uh advocacy for
civil disobedience right uh people want
to go out the street march without a
permit and get arrested for blocking
traffic uh at least if i were designing
the rules for twitter i would not rule
that out on the other hand if i were
someone were to be advocating murder or
uh
bank robbery and you know in a very
specific way we might roll that out so
uh there are some are some judgment
cases on there and then the other
content in this sense dangerous content
inherently dangerous content uh uh would
you know could include you know detailed
descriptions of how to make bombs or
poisons or how to kill yourself or
things of that ilk so that's that bundle
and uh
you know each each system will make its
own decisions about that i'm reasonably
confident elon will come up with some
reasonable
set of choices they're probably more
liberal than than many people might but
it's not going to be insane it's the
third bucket which is what i believe
elon actually cares about and which
could be so important to help our world
become a better place and that's what i
call point of view moderation
and point of view means what is it that
you are trying to deliver that you are
trying to say the substance are you
trying to say uh capitalism bad
communism good are you trying to say
trout fishing is more fun than bass
fishing you know you have some substance
that you're trying to deliver and that's
your point of view and
my perspective and i'm with you here i'm
pretty close to an absolutist on good
faith point of view uh you know as i
talk in the given example
in the essay that uh
all the platforms ganged up
simultaneously and booted the q anon
folks uh in late 2020 and very early
2021 you know frankly i think the q and
on folks are ass clowns and the chances
of their ideas being correct are
essentially zero uh at least mostly most
of their ideas are essentially zero but
then i as i said i also say the same
thing about christianity astrology and
marxist leninism and uh you know uh
i don't consider that
consider it right to ban those three
just because i don't like them right and
i think they're false and i think
they're bad and that's i do believe
they're both false and bad all three of
them yeah although i've heard you say
and i agree that there are things in
marx's critique of the way capitalism
functions that are well worth discussing
jesus says sermon on the mountain is a
goddamn good set of moral lessons
absolutely right and so
so that's an important thing for those
who who uh want a bright line to
recognize is that in the case that
something uh has value but it's not uh
all of one nature
how are you gonna draw that line and so
what you're saying is you draw that line
liberally because
you need to be able to push it out
if it's good faith if it's presented in
good decorum if it isn't obviously
imminently dangerous and not in the kind
of the new sense of safety [ __ ] we
can talk about that some uh but you know
uh then
let the ideas flow now this is what i
believe to be elon's actual uh
motivation and you know really hard for
me to think about
where in a point of view uh you know one
would stop and and again this is to you
were alluded to this earlier
yes that some bad ideas will float
around uh q anon marxist leninism let's
just give you know two examples uh but
the attempt to pick and choose amongst
ideas inevitably leads to the squelching
of these fresh shoots that we need and i
was in an email conversation with
somebody today and they were going blah
blah blah democracy
people were able to say whatever they
want to be the end of democracy and i
point out did you realize that when the
american founding democracy was a bad
word the founders went out of their way
to say that what they had created was
not a democracy it was a mixed republic
which was actually true it wasn't until
1800 or so when jefferson and his uh
democratic republican party got underway
that democracy even became something
other than an embarrassing word and very
partisan newspapers campaigned democracy
uh for a number of years and finally
democracy was more or less consolidated
in 1824 with the election that andrew
jackson narrowly lost to john quincy
adams and so
the thing that he thought he was
defending uh democracy is actually a
perfect example where upstart insurgents
waged memetic warfare for 24 years
before they actually consolidated the
idea that america was a democracy uh and
so if we're allowing the
peculiar oligarchs to control these
platforms uh to stomp on
fresh ideas no telling what fresh ideas
might be
being stomped on and i believe that it's
the fresh ideas that are going to save
humanity and help guide us
toward help us navigate ourself towards
a better place uh rather than you know
the old tired ideological ideas from the
18th 19th and 20th century and so
truthfully at bottom that's why i'm a
point of view near absolutist is that
i'm so afraid that uh you know reflexive
defense of the status quo ends up
killing the ideas that we're gonna need
to save ourselves and putting up with
some bad ideas in circulation is a price
worth paying to be able to harvest the
fruits of those fresh little sprouts
when they grow up
yeah this is a an issue near and dear to
my heart on many different fronts right
this is something that is now happening
in the realm of science it's obviously
happening in our political discussions
and
once you spot
the following puzzle
it's obvious that you can't go go about
this the way we're doing it the puzzle
is
the fringe
is mostly garbage
it is therefore
reasonable if you wanted to get an
algorithm to bet on things just simply
reflexively betting against the fringe
is a winner in general but it's not a
very big winner and what it does is it
guarantees that you will neuter all of
the things on which progress is based in
other words all of the status quo stuff
that works arose on the fringe and it
became mainstream and so effectively
this reflexive betting against the
fringe the dismissing of everyone on the
fringe as a kook or a crank or a quack
or whatever is the end of progress
right this is um
it is beyond conservative it is
reactionary and it doesn't matter which
side it's coming from that's just its
nature and in fact it's coming from uh
self-interest people who are trying to
protect themselves from competitors who
have yet to have
risen
will you know invoke this need to do
quality control of the fringe because
there's so much garbage there but the
point is you know the founding fathers
were fringe right
they were the enlightenment was friends
right in 1725 right science was
considered heretical literally people
were burned at the stake or
imprisoned for life galileo spent the
last years of his life under house
arrest for being the first real
scientist
right so it's it's effectively you know
are you for or against explosions well i
guess in general i don't want explosions
but you know internal combustion engines
run on explosions so if i rule out
explosions i've caused a problem
and you know in this case we have to
protect the fringe even though we also
have to acknowledge that it is true most
of what is on the fringe is garbage in
every era that's always been true and
the thing that has never been solved is
how you can go to the fringe and sort
between that which is ahead of its time
and that which is truly nonsense right
and our complexity lens would tell us
you can't you can't it can't because the
unfolding of a complex system is
unpredictable very many steps out so you
know something whack-a-doodle like game
b right uh is that the answer
i think it is but truthfully could i
prove it hell no and the only way you're
going to find out is to watch the world
unfold either game b will change the
world for the good or it'll disappear
right and in some sense i mean i you
know i hate to say the sentence because
i know that it will potentially invite
all kinds of nonsense but i think you
and i would both agree that in effect in
order to protect something potentially
important like game b you also have to
protect nonsense like q anon exactly
that was the point i was trying to make
if your job is to if your reflex if
you're even worse on facebook where they
actually write algorithms to do this uh
if your algorithms essentially are
targeting anything that is anti-status
quo uh as you'll say we'll never have
progress this is what happened to china
interestingly uh in the late ming era
where they had the biggest ships in the
world they went as far as uh
cape of good hope uh and then they got
their institutions got captured by this
hyper reactionaryism they burned all the
treasure ships and they basically fell
into centuries of
passive nothingness and then had their
butts kicked when the europeans and the
japanese emerged
and collided with them in the late 18th
and early 19th century and only now they
recovered and you know so that can
happen to a society it can just say
no change no change yes
that's a prescription for disaster in
fact my understanding of that chunk of
history is that it is
very likely maybe even near certain
uh that if the chinese had not uh done
that that
instead of the europeans
showing up in the americas it would have
been the chinese and
it would have changed the history of the
world
so anyway yes we need to be
incredibly cautious about
imagining that any rule of thumb is good
enough to deal with the problem of a
fringe that is mostly garbage but is
also the incubator for all of the most
important ideas of the future that none
of us can spell out yet right and to
speak to your own field
as we know the vast preponderance of
mutations are bad uh right the vast
republic i don't pick a number 99.9
right but guess what we'd still be
single cell uh bacteria or archaea if it
wasn't for mutations
yep right
um
so all right we've got a bunch of stuff
here i did want to mention that you talk
about
um
the question of doxing
and you deal with that i believe
according to what you've just said
as a form of content that does not need
to be protected whereas i would say that
in the case of doxing actually you can
deal with that by saying this is a
violation of decorum
but you can't there is no place to put
the decorum line that does the full work
right so for example
uh let's just take a a real life example
here
i
um retweeted a clip of a
speech that i had delivered on video at
the anti-mandate rally in los angeles
last month
or maybe it was the beginning of this
month
in any case in that clip
i argued that
um we are effectively faced with
questions that were settled at nuremberg
and we are now unsettling those
questions and that in fact these
mandates because
we have not been given
uh full information on the consequences
of things like these vaccines they are a
violation of our right to informed
consent and therefore
the
orders
to administer these things are immoral
and must be rejected so there are two
violations of nuremberg in the one case
of mandates now we can argue about
whether or not i'm correct in my
interpretation but nonetheless what i
have effectively said is that we are
morally required
to
reject what may be lawful orders
to administer a mandate that violates
the informed consent of patients now is
that a case of me advocating to break
the law is that equivalent of me
suggesting that someone should rob a
bank or is this me actually saying
that as a settled matter
of moral principle we all recognized
until five minutes ago
that we were required to
ignore
immoral orders to reject them in favor
of a higher principle right so the
question is
this now puts us in a you know a gray
area um anybody who recognizes the
importance of nuremberg is not going to
want some algorithm to regard that as me
advocating the breaking of some law as
if i've argued that you should you know
drive 150 miles an hour through a school
zone right
um
but there is a question to be
adjudicated right is that that's a good
that's a good uh test case actually and
it's one that you know the the answer to
me
is instinctually obvious that yeah uh
it's it smells to me very much the same
as
being allowed to advocate for civil
disobedience right which you say that uh
in civil disobedience whatever the minor
social costs are for minor criminal
activity like blocking a street uh or
even building a bonfire in the middle of
the street uh the uh the ability to
speak truth to power uh is worth taking
on small uh costs of criminal
infractions
and uh in this case i say very similar
again the whatever crimes they're that
you're advocating for they're not
violent they're not predatory uh they're
essentially what they call malam in uh
malam proper hebrew versus malam in say
there's an interesting distinction in
the law malam and say are laws that
any sane person would agree should be
illegal murder robbery arson rape
assault that kind of stuff uh uh
prohibi improhibum uh
is
laws that are essentially regulatory and
that societies will differ on right
failure to file your federal election
commission report on time is actually a
felony good for five years in the united
states at the current time uh the
founding fathers would have thought that
was utterly absurd and in most countries
around the world they don't have such
things so that's a classic prohema style
law
so perhaps there you know there we go
talking out loud thinking doing real
thinking as our friend jordan would say
as opposed to simulated thinking a first
cut would be uh
malem in say laws at the felony level
should not be
permitted
but to advocate breaking a regulatory
law that
humans in general don't agree is a crime
uh maybe that's okay
yep
so uh i would also point out i think to
me one of the most interesting things in
your article
was you know it's it's classic jim rut
it's also classic game b
people will find some analogy in it
between what you've done and and the
structure of the unity 2020 proposal but
in your article
you propose a an adjudication mechanism
that solves many of the problems that
many people would throw up their hands
at right if you're going to you know
we've got a basic decorum versus content
distinction
right we're going to enforce some rules
of decorum because the harm of doing so
is very very small but somebody's going
to have to decide whether a given
violation is decorum or content and then
within content
we're going to have to have uh
adjudication of whether or not something
like the case that i've just presented
is within the scope of tolerated
behavior on twitter or outside of the
bounds right so how are you going to do
that are you going to have some gigantic
structure a baroque court system inside
of twitter how could it be paid for how
do you keep it from being abused in the
way that our court systems and the
outside world are frequently abused so
anyway do you want to describe the
structure that you propose yes yeah
that's great because i do think this is
important because anything has to be
able to scale at a reasonable price
right
and so what i propose is first whatever
the rules are on a platform they need to
be laid out very much like the criminal
law which is with sections numbered
sections and numbered paragraphs
uh you know
12.4.3 right that's the that's the crime
of picking a pocket let's say
and that the bottom level the leaf on
these trees should be no more than 100
words that should be written in plain
english
that's the starting point you know if
law is not comprehensible uh you can't
hold people accountable uh for obeying
it second any moderation uh
action of any sort including warnings
must
specify the exact post in question and
must
quote the exact section that you are in
violation of
uh and it is true that that may have to
be done algorithmically at times however
those algorithms will fail at a pretty
high rate and so all algorithmic
moderation must be appealable to a human
within 24 hours uh and then that's the
first level of appeal then the second
level appeal i think is the one that is
really necessary for producing the
healthy ecosystem is something i came up
with and i'm pretty proud of it actually
which is if you've been rejected by your
human right of appeal against the
algorithm
you can
take your case uh to arbitration uh with
third-party american arbitration
association certified arbitrators and
i've used them before in in a business
at scale around domain squatting of all
obscure [ __ ] where we basically had a
relationship with an army of arbitrators
and they arbitrated the cases and it
worked uh they're not perfect but
they're way better than an internal
bureaucracy with all of its self-serving
tendencies and so this is what would
happen i'm not happy with my human
appeal from the
you know the 13 an hour staffer at
twitter so i say i'm going to
arbitration and here's how arbitration
works uh you put up a hundred dollars or
more uh
and you are the uh ostensible violator i
made the violator uh put up 100 minimum
or more and i appeal and the arbitration
is what's called baseball arbitration in
the art of uh arbitration which is the
arbitrator may not split the baby they
must decide either a or b
either the
the tweet or comment
uh
violates that 100 word or less uh
statute or it does not a or b it has to
be brisk and arbitrators know how to do
this fair amount of arbitration is
structured as baseball arbitration and
now here's the two clever parts
if uh
you find for the platform the
appellant the user loses their stake
let's say they're a hundred dollars uh
and that hundred dollars if it's only a
hundred dollars goes to pay for the
arbitrator uh on the other hand if the
platform loses and the
baseball arbitration is found for the uh
complainer the user they get 10x the
money from the platform so i put up 100
bucks
and if the arbitrator finds in my favor
i get a thousand dollars from twitter
and now a step further uh just for uh
many people hundred dollars is really
too much and further a hundred a
thousand dollars is not enough of a
penalty for really bad behavior uh so i
uh provided this plan to for stakes to
be as large as a million dollars right
uh and so worst case platforms paying 10
million when they're wrong and further
very important that there's a
marketplace the ability for anybody who
think they've been done wrong by the
platform to post uh their appeal and
syndicate it meaning that a community of
frankly some of them just gonna be
sharky financial dudes right they're
gonna look at the uh
the tweet they're gonna look at the uh
mandated hundred word statute they're
gonna say that doesn't apply [ __ ] i'm
gonna back this bet right and uh if they
back the bet
the backers will get 80 percent of the
win in the case that the
appealer prevails and the appealer gets
20 percent so he has an upside uh if he
can get his appeal uh syndicate i think
it's ten thousand dollars worth of uh
backers uh and uh he wins uh just paid
out a hundred thousand dollars uh he the
appellant gets twenty thousand dollars
we're not doing anything except
appealing and injustice uh and so the
net emergent result uh is that anybody
can get justice uh the justice is
self-liquidating in terms of its cost
uh the deciders are independent and
professional deciders uh who are not
under the thumb of uh of twitter and
american orchestration association does
a great job of protecting their
arbitrators from any kind of recourse
from the uh from either side in the
operation uh
and because of the ten to one leverage
uh the platforms uh will lose their ass
if they're not right ninety percent of
the time uh and so i look at this
combination of force fields which this
proposal creates and i just feel really
good about this that uh people will now
feel that moderation is transparent as
we know the rules we can read them
they're in plain english
when we uh
when they claim we violated the rules
not one you have violated our terms of
service i mean that's what most of these
things are these are you violated term
service you go to facebook's terms of
service 64 pages of gobbledygook right
but if they have to quote the exact
hundred words which uh which correspond
to this exact post then you can
understand what you allegedly did wrong
you can make the decision whether uh you
feel like you have been done in
injustice and if you have been you could
appeal you could make some money off it
make them pay
we all know one of the human senses of
justice is to inflict a penalty on
people who do you harm right so one of
the things that keeps coming up in the
uh research on deep human nature that
punishing evil doers is something that
humans actually like to do even above
and beyond the
uh the rewards that might come from it
so that's my that's my proposal which i
think if you implemented it on something
like twitter
would revolutionize uh both people's
attitudes about moderation and uh the
actual goodness of the result all right
so let me give you a couple observations
on this one doesn't have to be
professional arbiters it could be i like
your structure i think it would be
useful but you could also source this
work from inside the community in
various ways
also doesn't have to be individuals you
know it could be that certain cases are
important enough that you would want to
have more eyes and a debate process
inside the adjudication
the
structure as you propose it and i know
you're going to agree with this
i'll be surprised if you don't let's put
it that way i mean i will be surprised
if you disagree
is
the structure as you've laid it out is a
great prototype were you to implement it
you would almost certainly discover that
the parameters are set incorrectly right
that you could get away
uh
you know that either the process is uh
too likely to bar certain kinds of
people from getting important things
adjudicated because they don't have the
hundred bucks or aren't likely to risk
it and their uh case isn't likely to
garner the attention of somebody who's
waiting for a particularly golden
version or who knows but the point is
the parameters as laid out are likely
not to be right they're a good first
guess but we don't know what the right
parameters are until you've run it so
what you want is a system in which that
can evolve and the fine tuning of the
system so it works maximally efficiently
covers the maximum number of cases and
does so reasonably well
you know comes out
in the wash
i also believe that there needs to be a
feedback between this process
and
i will argue i did argue on twitter this
morning that there needs to be a bill of
rights right now the bill of rights
should spell out what the intent of the
various per
provisions are
and so as the system of adjudication
that you've laid out gets refined it
will also reveal ambiguities in the
terms of service and the bill of rights
for users
and so that feedback can be used to
refine those things so that any
ambiguities get rung out of the system
so that the uh you know unspotted
problems get introduced in
in some formal way and then the
parameters around them get refined and
this could all be done must all be done
transparently so that people can discuss
the process they can discuss the moral
hazards that may arise etc etc so those
inter-interacting feedbacks can both
refine the adjudication and
the
structure of the effective laws that are
being
laws or standards that are being
adjudicated
yep i like
quite a bit of this i'll go through the
parts i like and then the one part that
i considered what you proposed and
rejected it okay uh first i love the
idea of a bill of rights right you know
and in the same sense that the founding
fathers forgot to add a bill of rights
to the constitution uh the madisonians
jeffersonians demanded it and they got
it so i think that's a wonderful idea
and that should be one of the basis is
on which you appeal which is uh you know
not only did i not violate uh rule
12.3.4 but 12.3.4 violates the seventh
amendment of of twitter and either of
those would be would be grounds for the
arbitrator uh to find against it of
course uh twitter pays out ten thousand
dollars to somebody because they uh
arbitrator found a a rule was
unconstitutional they're going to change
that rule damn quick otherwise people
are going to mind the [ __ ] out of that
right so that's a
that's i think a very uh good uh good
idea of course you're correct i mean you
know of course you're correct the
parameters that i propose are not the
correct ones they're the ones i made up
when i wrote the essay right they're a
good first guess yeah they're not
terrible but of course they're going to
change right it turned out probably that
a million dollars is too high maybe the
cap should be ten thousand dollars uh
something like that uh hard to see how
you get professional arbitration for
much less than a hundred dollars on a
consistent basis maybe get to 50 but uh
at scale but you know if you're going to
use a professional arbitration uh you're
gonna have to have the minimum of a
hundred uh
and now i i am sympathetic to the issue
about you know let's say about the kid
in nigeria who makes you know five
dollars a day he can't come up with a
hundred dollars but that's where i
perhaps have more confidence in
rapacious investors right uh you know
that if there are
uh you know there is money to be made
especially the cap is ten thousand
dollars and you uh can find a kid in
nigeria who has done injustice by
uh who's posted his claim uh there will
be sharks they'll be looking for those
things this is injustice i'm putting the
whole 10 grand down i'm going to win 80
thousand dollars if i'm right and i
believe that uh i'm in fact all i have
to be right is 12 percent of the time
right so i guess i'm enough of a market
purist in some sense uh that i have more
confidence that a marketplace in
syndicated appeals will actually work
pretty good all right i i'll dig it but
then we got to go one more step
before we do that okay let me finish up
on the one part that i considered and
rejected uh you didn't quite say it
explicitly but you alluded to it uh
which is maybe there's other ways to
adjudicate these cases than a
third-party arbitration and one that i
used to love i used to actually propose
this
uh is automatically selected juries of
users for this sort of thing and i
actually as i started to write the
article i actually wrote that in then i
would stop and thought about it what
would happen if you did that and i
realized there's a flaw in it
unfortunately because it's a great idea
and for years i've advocated and here's
the flaw that i saw
unfortunately societies today are highly
highly tribalized knee-jerk tribalism uh
so if you let's let's say and this was
mike going to be my proposal that uh you
know a a decorum
particularly decorum violations would
would that were low stakes so the worst
that could happen to you is the content
was taken down or maybe a three-day
suspension so anything uh you know lost
relatively low stakes would go to a
randomly selected of currently active
users of ten of them uh and to make the
same call as the arbitrator uh and if
you know somebody who was picked didn't
make the call the algorithm would keep
sending it to people until ten of them
had voted and if eight voted against you
you lost right uh now uh unfortunately
humans being where they are especially
today suppose i uh you know say donald
trump is a [ __ ] right it's
against the rules to say [ __ ]
people hate donald trump are gonna say
that's not a violation right
and so uh
motivated reasoning would triumph over
careful application of the rules and
therefore i rejected my own idea
as i was writing the article well i
reject your rejection of your own idea
jim
let's see
let's see if i can't resurrect it
okay let's do it all right well that was
that was what you were alluding to was
my guess absolutely absolutely well
here's the thing hey i think it's such a
good idea that i don't want the
tribalism objection to kill it but i
totally recognize your point is that
basically if all you're doing is
subjecting a particular question to the
arbitrary process of how many people you
know you know of whether you picked one
person from this side or that side of
the puzzle
but here's the thing
i do hope and i think it is imperative
that musk
makes
transparent whatever
algorithmic stuff is affecting
who we interact with and how we view
them and all of that
but
it is also true
that the algorithms
are in a position to figure out who
is
not subject to those tribal dynamics in
other words
i don't know what the algorithm thinks
about you
and i don't know what it thinks about me
but i bet it's confused
right i would say most likely it would
have to be because the point is you get
into a level of a la carte uh
evaluations of things and every you know
beyond some level everybody's one-off
and yeah big data can overcome some of
that but anyway my point is
the
algorithms are in a position where at
least the the data matrix is in a
position to identify people who are in a
good position to adjudicate these things
people who you know
um people who have
a consistent history of nuance in some
area that makes their position somewhat
unpredictable from a machine perspective
could be found
and so it could even become
uh you know a badge of honor in other
words to be spotted as somebody who's
capable of adjudicating these things
could be an indication that you're
actually a nuanced independent thinker
and that could be a badge of honor which
would then incentivize people to get off
their tribal [ __ ] which would be good
for society so anyway somewhere in that
neighborhood might be a solution to the
the
hazard you rightly point out is a
sizable one
interesting that's and
and here's a way to tell if you're right
uh and the company the size of twitter
with elon musk's billions could do this
which is at some substantial scale big
enough that was statistically
significant do both in parallel
yep in other words and if the
uh
yeah yeah maybe test it yeah a b test it
have the arbitrators do it we can have
pretty high reliability that arbitrators
are good there's a lot of literature on
that they're not perfect but they're
good
and if it turns out that finding these
untriggered people these people who are
not tribal in their decisions or have
the intellectual fortitude to override
their tribalism and i do know people
like that uh you know that my mother was
a famously fair person you know i would
uh put my life on the line if my mother
was on a jury she was somehow able to
get her tribal alliances which were
quite strong uh and put them aside when
she was making a judgment right but i
know you find that with a computer
algorithm i don't know but uh but we
could test it right okay brett and his
gang of renown uh create or evolve most
likely from machine learning uh
you know a proposed mechanism and then
we run it in parallel with the
arbitrators and if it doesn't beat the
arbitrators we don't adopt it if when it
can consistently uh equal the
arbitrators uh then maybe we'll consider
it not we will consider we will adopt it
uh so now with respect to this other
thing that you alluded to you might as
well go on to this which is uh the
algorithms and transparency and this is
something that uh i believe elon has
gotten almost right
which is he suggested that the feed
algorithm be made open source
you know because you as most people know
you don't see all the tweets of your
friends in their time order in which
they were made you used to on both
facebook and twitter but it's been many
years and frankly an awful lot of their
money uh comes from uh feeding you click
bait and things that will keep you on
drive engagement etc and nobody knows
what those algorithms do their magic
right and people think they've been
shadow banned for shadow banning is the
idea that based on the content or or you
or something they
feed less of your stories uh to people
who follow you i've occasionally been
fairly convinced i've been shadow banned
for people
you have to be careful because there are
multiple patterns one pattern i've seen
which
uh you will spot right away why it
exists
is
that when you take a break from twitter
twitter is very tepid on your tweets at
the point that you return
right that's very true and as somebody
who takes a six-month sabbatical from
social media every year
it does take a while to warm the
algorithms up when i get back right
which i take to be
effectively punishment to keep addicts
on right it's very addictive you know
when my tweets are you know regularly
getting four thousand six thousand eight
thousand
likes and then i take a break for a week
and i come back
and i you know
stuff isn't getting seen
it trains me actually those breaks for a
week aren't so good for you brett and
um anyway
it's basically a lot of sense a lot huge
amount of sense and god damage does that
suck right god damn does that suck and
the thing is i can't even swear i mean
i'll bet you that they understand what
they're doing but it's the kind of thing
that if they have a learning algorithm
what you know what biases cause people
to remain engaged on twitter it will
discover the pattern of how to punish
somebody who's trying to control their
addiction and it will generate that
algorithm so this algorithm generates
more actual views than that algorithm
the management may not even know
that it has this feature and in fact
that's one of the dangers of black box
machine learning
blackbox machine learning is damaged
useful for certain things but for things
like this uh with no transparency in it
uh it could produce very bad
unanticipated i never thought of that
but you're exactly right that's got to
be true i mean especially the guys who
are growing massive machine learning
which they're mostly facebook and google
i guarantee either intensely or
unintentionally
uh they are punishing people who stop
shooting up the heroine and if you wanna
if you wanna be a paperclip
that's the thing to root for that's the
thing that's gonna get you turned into a
paperclip faster than anything else is
these black boxes where the people who
made them don't know why they work right
they work
they were given you know we want lots of
papers left you're gonna get some whole
bunch of paper clips [ __ ] but
anyway now back to my solution and where
uh on where i think uh he's half right
or uh sixty percent right uh
that feed algorithm ought to be uh
open source not that uh you know i was
talking to my wife about this and she's
a very smart person but she's not a
software person she said i don't know
what i would do with that well you don't
need to do anything with it there are
professional critics out there who will
evaluate the software and they'll say oh
look at this it's done just brett said
the [ __ ] they punish you if you
go on break uh and then everybody would
know it and start complaining and maybe
they'd fix it
but the other the downside is it would
also provide lots of clues for how to
game the algorithm
yeah and
that's not good so here's my response to
that here's my solution
which is all right let's have a market
in feed algorithms and they're all
required to be open source
and
and you can charge up to 10 cents a
month to somebody to subscribe uh to
your feed algorithm and they're all open
source and and and more important and
also very importantly uh the
architecture of facebook uh
does not
you other users do not know what
algorithm you're running so they don't
know how to gain you so suddenly the uh
the gaming of the algorithms problem
becomes exponentially more difficult and
so i think you get the power of open
source algorithms you get innovation and
algorithms which itself is a pure good
and you get a dense and complicated
ecosystem which is very difficult to
gain yeah but there's a big danger in
that jim
you know if you take that
i know there are some there are some
dangers well this is like the mother of
all dangers right if you take that
thinking too far
you could end up saving western
civilization right for that to happen i
know wouldn't that be terrible yeah
because if people had too much insight
into the way they were being manipulated
and started to understand why other
people see things the way that they do
then they would be much harder to fool
right
and actually so this is my my
elaboration of that idea as it happens i
was working with some other folks about
what to do about the collapse of all of
our platforms which
may not matter because elon may be in
the process of rescuing twitter and if
he does that will change the dynamics
for the rest of the you know if the rest
of
these social media platforms are like
the kiddie pool and twitter is like a
place that adults can go and have any
conversation that needs to be had then
twitter's going to be the only place
anybody wants to be so that's going to
change what the other platforms do this
is an extension of my zero as a special
number
uh claim but
anyway
one of the things that i think
is
true um you know and
this is a response to celia's point
about not knowing what to do with the
algorithm if even if it was open is i
don't even think that that's right
because
one of the things you might build in
is a it could be sliders
right where you could just play with
them and see how your view of the world
changes as you move yourself from
twitter thinks i'm a liberal to twitter
thinks i'm a conservative or something
like that
but you could also there's all kinds of
fun things you could do right hey
you know brett weinstein sounds crazy to
me i cannot understand how a smart
person would reach the conclusions that
he seems to have reached about for
example coveted public health policy
let me see the world as brett sees it
for a week
right then maybe you'll understand a few
things right now if you could do that if
you could say look
i want
to see what my opposite you know take
every parameter that describes me and
flip them all the other direction what
does that person see on twitter now this
begins to empower us as citizens to
understand the crazy world we've landed
in right i think this could be
and i have i have wondered about this
for
oh at least a decade why is
why is there not a cottage industry of
people trying to reverse engineer
moment-to-moment the content of these
algorithms so that we can you know put a
corrective lens on them and stop seeing
through
some you know baroque structures desired
viewpoint right why are you there is an
industry right it's people who are
basically trying to promote stuff right
the influencer type stuff it's all about
uh you know how to game the algorithms
there's a giant industry in how to gain
the algorithms true but there's no
public spirited effort to allow you to
correct for the algorithm's uh impact on
you so anyway the point is look if you
give users the ability to play with the
parameters see what other people see
right that
could potentially be a game changer with
respect to how we understand each other
yeah i love that and i love that you
combine it with with the marketplace
idea because uh that way there would be
innovation in these sliders right okay
we're kind of not just right left that's
kind of stupid how about open-minded
versus closed-minded how about neurotic
versus anti-neurotic right uh you know
you could sli you could have all kinds
of interesting ideas uh or or again
someone could actually put i want to
look i want to look at the world the way
kim kardashian looks at it for 30
seconds before i went insane
and there'd be lots of innovation in the
features around feeds so but i love your
idea and frankly i've never thought
about that that's a that's a great one
i'm stealing that i'll give i'll give
credit when i remember that brett
weinstein said that we should uh
have
sliders on our feed owl goals and uh be
able to switch shoes with other people
and see the world from there that alone
see the world from their perspective for
even if it's just an hour would be
really quite valuable oh my god it would
be so great and you can imagine you know
the podcasts that are just waiting to
happen somebody runs an experiment right
what you know i i lived for a week in
jesse's singles shoes right let me tell
you what i learned about the difference
in our perspective there's so much room
you know for us to become sort of like
next level conscious of our collective
consciousness
that uh it's it's hard to imagine how it
wouldn't be uh
invigorating and tremendously insightful
yes the uh you know the big heads say
multi-perspective right literally you'd
have an opportunity to be
multi-perspective i could look at the
world as brett sees it i can look at the
world as kim kardashian sees it i can
look at the way heaven forbid trump sees
it and uh that would be educational for
short periods of time sure
and that's really hard to do you know
it's hard it's impossible to do in a
face-to-face world other than through
empathy
and but this is literally a place where
our technology could provide us a
capacity we never had before totally
could and for a troublemaker like elon
musk
this is i think a natural right elon
give us a call we'll tell you how to do
it well actually that that does raise a
question right
which is
um you know
you've been thinking about this stuff
forever
game b
was an explicit effort to figure out if
we could get ourselves out of you know
the
the eddy that we were being flushed down
to some new kind of self-governance
that wasn't coercive and accomplished
all of the things that it needs to
accomplish and was resistant to capture
and all of the things that we understood
game b to be about
there's a question about whether or not
if this was
if it sounded like the style of thinking
was of the right sort to figure out what
to do with a property like twitter that
has huge potential to do both good and
ill
right
he could create a council
and you know
we could figure it out and if we didn't
figure it out
he could chuck us yeah we could
buy buy his fancy dinners for uh you
know
here's an idea you know three day
weekends every six weeks for a while
right that was the pattern we used to
cook up the emancipation party in game b
and then when he decides we're not
getting any value no more free dinners
gentlemen and uh i think we could cook
up something for him yeah i'm pretty
confident of it i think so all the
people you and i know together uh you
know we've been thinking about this
stuff in a way more nuanced way because
i do warn i do i do worry about that i
do think that elon and his move taking
over twitter has an opportunity to break
the monopoly of these goddamn silicon
valley blue church
discourse chokers
but i also think that there is a chance
he could [ __ ] it up really really bad
and actually make things worse and it's
really important that he gets some good
advice because he's a brilliant guy but
i made this point also online today it's
kind of weird jumping back into social
media after you know uh
almost a month being away from it
because i had i did say when i went on
sabbatical that i would come back to
post my post my podcast episodes which
my producer actually does so i don't
have to dirty my fingers with the filthy
environment of social media but i also
said i would do it when i posted essays
and so i did hop back in today one of
the things i uh
made the point on
was that elon as someone said well you
know i must have figured this out he's
brilliant and i go yeah he's mother
[ __ ] brilliant but let's look at all
the problems he solved they all live in
the realm of the complicated
uh their engineering problems you know
even spacex which is magnificent huge
scale engineering is still engineering
and when we say something is complicated
we means we can take it apart put it
back together again and it will still
work
uh
twitter is in the rain is in the realm
of the complex
yep it's basically networks it's not
linear it's humans it's game theory it's
a a genetic game theory the worst kind
and uh unlike the complicated you can't
take complex systems apart put it back
together again and they'll work they
just they're just different and so i
would put up as a finger up saying yeah
elon musk an extremely impressive guy in
the land of the complicated uh but he
has really no expertise at all on the
land of the complex and while i believe
he's so smart
he could learn how to use that lens he
needs some lens makers for the realm of
the complex
i absolutely agree and um you know
that's a it's such an important
distinction because to almost everybody
complex and complicated uh
sound like synonyms right and until you
spot the uh huge distinction and its
implications for something like this
because whether you like it or not
twitter is a
living dynamic
you know with i don't know how many
presumably it's billions of users
hundreds of billions hundreds of
millions hundreds of millions hundreds
of millions of users each of which is a
complex system in and of itself which
virtually guarantees that the
inter-reaction if it's anything other
than stupidly simple
uh is going to be a uh
a
highly complex complex system yeah each
one's gonna be not only complex adaptive
systems but it's gonna be strategic
which adds a whole nother level to the
analysis as it turns out yep so anyway
yes uh
whether it's
complex systems is your fundamental bent
or evolutionary biology you definitely
need some
you know at the very least you need
people who know that they don't know the
solution and that
you're going to have to basically
use an evolutionary dynamic to solve any
problem and that you will discover you
know unending unintended consequences
along that road and they will have to be
dealt with in real time
that that is a fundamental piece of the
puzzle yeah which is very different than
building a tesla car or even more so a
rocket where you have to be extremely
disciplined very
extremely disciplined thinking could
lead you into disaster in twitter land
you're going to have to be adaptive in
near real time as you say much like we
talked about anti-utopianism
you're nudging twitter in better
directions i actually closed out my
essay with that point
which is
anyone who thinks that
any group of people
but specifically eon is going to get it
right and do it perfectly from the
beginning no [ __ ] way
the best we can hope for is that we'll
be moving in the right direction and
doing more smart things than we are
stupid things and that uh rejecting elon
because he's not perfection uh is the
classic example of giving up the good
for the perfect and uh and again on the
other hand with elon without the right
guidance might not even be good but i
think there's a good chance that uh
particularly if they can find wise folks
like you and me to give him advice uh
the this will be a massive improvement
over
uh having our ideas uh of the green
chutes of these new important ideas
being stomped on uh by the peculiar
oligarchs of silicon valley uh and i
think this will be great but we'll see
well let's put it this way um i you know
i said on twitter the other day that
this could be a disaster but i would bet
strongly in the other direction because
i do um i i am a believer that elon uh
has interesting instincts and he's very
good at problem solving and so he's
going to spot the part of this that uh
nobody is equipped to handle yet
i will say in your essay
you point to his
it's not really a ted talk it's a
conversation on the ted channel
and i only got
a short way into it before i had to to
put it on pause but i was struck because
he is explaining in there
why so the question was some of your
predictions have been almost
uh strangely spot on but other ones have
been way off why the distinction and the
one that was used as the exemplar for
why are you way off sometimes
was when are we going to get
fully autonomous cars
and what he describes is
a
series of
diminishing returns curves stacked on
each other he calls them false horizons
um and i was struck because
this is actually an image from uh
heather and my book
um we went looking for versions of this
image this is a an idea i came up with
years ago as i was working on trade-offs
which was my my dissertation
and i realized that there was
a parameter that was causing
certain patterns to emerge in nature and
it has a very different effect in for
example academia where it causes fields
to get stuck right which is a pattern
most people aren't familiar with they
sort of think there's always progress
going on because they're always papers
being published but that's not how it
goes and there's a very good reason for
it
but anyway i was struck by the fact that
he was effectively describing
uh this figure in our book which
uh we you know made great pains to
construct we couldn't just find a
version of it somewhere because it
didn't
exist i'll tell you where it does exist
which is in the uh
sfi and flavored study of innovation
uh what we have found is that innovation
is a whole c is a stack of s-curves
uh at various scales and one of the ones
that the people at stanford institute
have studied uh more than most others is
uh machine generated motion
uh actually motion in general
so you start out with walking then you
get a horse and like then it tops off
the best arabian horse uh is only a bit
better than a sort of half-assed horse
you buy for ten dollars right uh and
that but it s out horse ain't going no
faster than the best horse in the world
uh then you get a steam engine right you
get a simple steam engine that's not
optimized thermodynamically it can't go
faster about 30 miles an hour
tops out then someone comes up with a
new innovation there's another s-curve
and if you look at the history of
transport uh it's
s curve after s curve after s curve with
uh middling uh innovations like the more
efficient condensers on the steam
engines
to totally radically new ideas like
diesel then diesel electric and then gas
turbine and jets and then rockets and
those are all separate s's
and so there's where you i think you can
find this idea laid out in some
considerable details right but the point
is you can also extrapolate from it
right if you know that that's the
process you're involved in and you're on
your first s curve then you behave
differently than if you think finally we
figured out how to do this and then
you're deeply into diminishing returns
before you ever decide to do anything
else and so
take for example the academic context
somebody discovers something new they
have an insight in a field right maybe
it's einstein
who
finds the flaw in newtonian physics and
opens up this brand new line of inquiry
right that brand new line of inquiry is
going to pay dividends
at a spectacular rate and the problem is
that what we infer from that is that
this is the truth rather than this is
the next s curve and the school of
thought that owns all of those gains in
what we call the bargain phase
ends up killing off all its competitors
so at the point that it hits diminishing
returns which is predictable enough
there's nobody left who remembers how to
think any other way because the school
of thought that was so dominant taught
all of the students and so
if you realize this is the pickle you're
in
then you realize that the obvious thing
to do is never to whittle down to one
school of thought you at least need the
second most vibrant school of thought to
be uh fed and protected through lean
times because that's likely i mean this
goes back to the conversation we were
having at the beginning of this about
what's on the fringe you know what's on
the fringe is the school of thought uh
that's on the outs because something
else is paying high dividends but of
course that's a finite process until
you've got the ultimate diminishing
returns curve until you've discovered
you know enough of the truths that there
is in the next one
which is a long way out physics actually
fell into this uh in a famous way uh
the the search for the theory of
everything in string theory uh and
the funding flew to string theorists the
phd wannabe students came to the
theorists and instead of cranking out
one phd student a year as is typical for
a physicist they were cranking out five
and by the early double lots this is
astounding number 60 of the graduating
phds in physics were string theory
people
well it's turned out string theory
maybe there's something there for in the
very long term but at least in the
term
short term it appears to be a bit of a
dry hole and so physics had to
essentially rediversify itself from
relatively small islands that were
outside of string theory now it's done
so but essentially it may have lost a
whole generation of physicists who got
over sucked into the vortex of string
theory right and now i uh always point
out that in part
the poor discipline of physicists with
respect to the term theory
is part of the problem here because
there's no evidence for string theory
it's it's purely a hypothesis it's not
even a hypothesis right because in order
to be a hypothesis it would have to
point to the experiment it would have to
be testable and so my point is this is
actually string notion yeah this doesn't
make you wrong truthfully it's string
math so far and apparently the math is
so beautiful i'm not a serious
mathematician yeah i can do differential
equations and [ __ ] like that but but
theoretical math ain't my thing but the
people that look at the string theory
say it is beautiful math and that's
really all it is so far uh now there are
there it is possible that there will be
some experiments
but nobody's even been able to
conceptualize one that we could do in
the next hundred years right which is a
little scary so it's
to your point discipline of supplying
the scientific method it should
definitely not be called a theory yeah
and calling it a hypothesis is uh with a
grace and a nod about the fact that they
can speculate about some experiments
they might be able to do in 200 years
hopefully it becomes a hypothesis at
some point in the meantime it's string
cheese that's my feeling i like it so
yeah at least small i know i've had on
my show
has written very eloquently about uh the
bad attractor in physics that grossly
overstaffed
string mathematics
for a considerable period of time and
probably
slowed
the human species
rate of innovation down up to a
measurable degree because an awful lot
of our uh
fundamental advances come from physics
if people had been working in solita
physics around uh the parasitism that
occurs at the four nano level level in
computer chips we might be a whole uh
generation ahead in computer chips for
example yeah just it's an interesting
thing yeah
opportunity cost is a is a [ __ ]
absolutely absolutely
so what else do we want to talk about
here i'm going to have to run in about
10 minutes but uh
well i don't know
we've done a pretty good job here i mean
i do think i guess there is one other
thing that i i want to talk about all
right let's hop into it
um
i think you know in in watching people's
reaction
uh to elon's successful takeover of
twitter
i'm struck by the fact that it brings up
an echo of another conversation all
right i often say i'm sure you won't
disagree with this either
that the best form of governance is sure
to be
um a a brilliant benevolent dictator and
that the problem with the benevolent
dictator plan
is two things one there's a question of
whether they remain benevolent at the
point that they accumulate power i don't
think it's as certain
as many people would have you believe
that every person becomes corrupt upon
having great power but i do think
there's something about power that tends
to accumulate corrupt people but the
second thing
and maybe even the more critical flaw of
a benevolent dictator
program is
uh there's no rational way there's no
handoff plan that keeps
something in the hands of a benevolent
dictator but anyways there's a third one
too which is uh for any big problem the
benevolent dictator was a benevolent
dictator for the janitor your school it
might be great uh but uh benevolent
dictator for uh you know a country uh he
needs a whole bureaucracy and the
bureaucracy inevitably becomes corrupt
women especially if it's only answering
to one person and their careers are in
his hand forever
okay i i take that i agree with you um
but in this case
i guess my feeling about the takeover of
twitter in principle if you said to me
you know
10 years ago are you in favor of
these giant tech platforms being in the
hands of
you know billionaires with effectively
absolute control over how they function
obviously my instinct would be hell no
that sounds pretty freaking dangerous
on the other hand at this point
am i willing to bet on a particular
uh
a billionaire who appears to have
a desire to solve extremely difficult
problems
and has a good head on his shoulder a
broad knowledge of uh different
disciplines
yeah in this case i'm willing to bet on
the kind of guy who could get electric
cars to where he's gotten them could get
a private space program to where he's
gotten it
and it doesn't mean that it's guaranteed
to work but it does mean that it beats
the hell out of any other alternative on
the table right we are talking about a
benevolent dictator but a benevolent
dictator that's closer to the janitorial
department at the school than it is to
you know
civilization as a whole
i'm with you there it's one of you
mentioned this is actually good because
if you if you'd asked me 10 years ago if
suppose the richest guy in the world who
made his money doing something entirely
else came in and took over one of the
main uh
online platforms uh to run it the way he
wants with an extreme point of view
probably i would have said almost
certainly a horrible idea because i
would imagine somebody like larry
ellison right or bill gates or somebody
like that or be like it'd be like jeff
bezos taking over the washington post
so that he could you know strangle
democracy in the darkness or something
exactly but yeah but yeah so i think
you're right that this is an
idiosyncratic and therefore risky
proposition but nonetheless it feels
right uh you know uh you know maybe
we're all wrong maybe the dude is just a
the usual vile [ __ ] that corporate
america throws up but it doesn't seem
like it i mean the guy seems authentic
he seems curmudgeonly he seems like he
doesn't give two [ __ ] what anybody
thinks uh all the things that in my
experience have made for people who can
do serious innovation and uh serious
innovation particularly in the because
he's gonna get unbelievable amount of
flack from the people who had this choke
hold around the discourse um and this
this is i think such a tell you know the
people who instinctively think elon move
is bad
uh most of them are not thinking at the
level we're talking about here they're
talking about the fact that their side
no longer will have the choke hold on
discourse you know they don't they may
not even realize yeah that's what's
motivating but this is motivated
thinking big [ __ ] time and uh so it's
a real towel the people are
instinctively ah the world will have to
be almost pitch over twitter
uh you know are are basically are
telling me that uh they don't want their
side to lose this this stick in the
fight yeah
they they do not like the idea that
somebody is going to disarm them and
create a level playing field because
they've been enjoying it you know
everything i can tell about uh elon
could be i could be wrong right
is he really sincerely wants
a good faith marketplace and ideas where
the good ideas will gradually build
support and prosper and the bad ideas
will gradually disappear and sink into
the into the ground now that's much
harder to do than it is to say but at
least he wants to do it right which
which is not something i see at any of
the other players well so here's the
there are a couple interesting pieces of
the puzzle that sit sit somewhere near
here
um one
there's something about the startup
process
that allows people to become
powerful without
being trained into corruption
in other words i think there's something
vibrant about
uh
startups
in large measure because they do have
this exponential growth potential which
can take quirky people who do have you
know their own way of viewing things and
put them in positions of of significant
power and it tends to erode away but
um
musk's rise has been so spectacular in
terms of the wealth at his disposal
that in some sense i think he carries
whatever values he's got obviously
they're not going to be completely
unchanged by what he's been through but
in some sense he's doing something that
looks more like what i would expect
somebody who became that wealthy to do
than what most really wealthy people do
right mostly
most really wealthy people most of the
billionaires look to me like it has made
them timid rather than bold and i don't
quite get it because i
feel like it should be exactly the
opposite way the people with [ __ ] you
money should be bolder about their
visions and bolder about doing something
wild and less concerned about failure
and i see a lot of the opposite and i
think that's weird that is strange but
it is very true uh you know that uh you
know the whole point of [ __ ] you money
is being able to say [ __ ] you and you
know truthfully i made my [ __ ] [ __ ] you
money pretty young and i have taken
advantage of that platform to say [ __ ]
you lots of times yes you have
but the but the people that don't i mean
why would you be
uh you know a you know a
multi-billionaire and to become a timid
toady what the hell is that about right
right
but we know elon's not that i i believe
hey elon if you're listening i believe
your game b and don't know it yet uh you
having sold all your mansions and got
rid of your fancy cars and live in a uh
eighty-five 000
uh shitbox house in west texas uh you
know the game b the game b spirit is in
the lab
right and uh i i you know again you can
be wrong uh but i got a good sense about
elon here that this particular place
he's not one of these people that's
fallen into timidity uh and and of
course
big part of it is not giving a [ __ ] what
the other rich dudes think right uh you
know you saw the kind of
fairly bad taste uh image he made of uh
of gates the other day that was pretty
good uh
yeah
but
uh you know that shows me he just
doesn't care and that's what you need
right now you need somebody who cares
about humanity uh cares about the
trajectory of the human race yeah
there's another sign that i tell that
he's a good guy he's obsessed with going
to mars yep by the way i think that's
probably a bad idea well it'll turn out
the asteroids are where we should go
first uh for a number of reasons but you
may be right and i may be wrong but the
fact that he has said things like i want
to be buried on mars right uh makes me
realize that this is not
jeff bezos or this is not larry ellison
or this is not uh whatever apparatchik
is running general motors these days
right this is a guy who
you know marches to the beat of a
different drum and that's just what we
need right now yeah i absolutely agree
and i think there is something quite
hopeful in it i i will say
that there is also something very
hopeful in uh mark andreessen's
uh recent exploration of what he's
calling uh the current thing um
this strikes me as a positive you know
another person who's achieved great
wealth doing something early in his life
that made him uh
quite wealthy and powerful
um and that you know i also know him a
bit he's quite a deep thinker and i know
it too i knew him before he got rich oh
is that right i was a mentor to him uh
he was a little rich but he wasn't you
know big swinging dick of the valley uh
it was back when he was the cto for aol
believe it or not oh my goodness we used
to hang out and uh you know i gave him
one of his first public speaking
opportunities and things of that sort uh
he is a
impressive he was an impressive young
man so i looked at it at the time he's
grown up to be a very impressive dude in
general yep absolutely uh
agree and i'm very favorable to the way
he is um you know turning
turning his attention to the way our
uh collective consciousness
uh works or more often than not doesn't
work
i think it's very productive and i have
to say i also
feel that there's something about what
peter thiel is up to at the moment
you know his speech at the bitcoin
conference also struck me as
um an important
bold move in which
you know he basically planted a flag and
he pointed to the uh the gerundocracy
and um
you know outlined what i thought was a
pretty interesting model of the way we
should think about bitcoin versus
ethereum etc
so anyway i don't know but i do have a
sort of sense you know and
somehow
pieces of gen x that have gotten
very wealthy and powerful through
unusual mechanisms that have left them
mentally intact are on the move and you
know i don't mean to say you know peter
thiel and i disagree on a whole bunch
about the way to view the world but
nonetheless i am
heartened to see that people are
actually up for a major change and that
i think
in some sense they are feeling the same
urgency that uh motivated
uh
game b and other such endeavors to start
thinking big
yeah there's something in the air right
now and frankly all you do is look
around see how [ __ ] up [ __ ] is and if
uh
if you're not blind then you should be
thinking about bold alternatives and it
is great uh though again we should
caution that have it being driven by
peculiar oladuct garx is a dangerous
strategy and that the people themselves
need to get some skin in the game here
and i think in some sense this is the
message we've converged on here this is
a dangerous strategy but it is so late
in our trajectory we are in such danger
that at some level
as dangerous as it is to have uh
oligarchs effectively navigating based
on their own understanding and the
understanding of those around them it's
a better plan than allowing this system
to continue on autopilot because it's
going to get us killed
here here
all right thanks so much jim this has
been uh really enlightening um i will of
course post a link to your piece i would
strongly encourage people to read it to
think about it and to extrapolate from
it figure out what we haven't figured
out that could be added to the
the model or critiques that need to be
made anyway it's a living discussion and
i look forward to seeing where it goes
ah thank you brett's been a wonderful
conversation and i think we actually
came up with some good new stuff here
today i think so too all right
be well jim and be well everyone else
all right bye-bye bye
[Music]